- I hope it's okay that
I mentioned The Goonies
because here's the thing,
it's probably your Since You've Been Gone.
That's the song every--
That's the only song
people think I've done
in my career, I feel like, sometimes.
And I'm like, cool, there's other songs.
And I know there's other movies.
There's a plethora of many
movies that you're in,
that you're amazing, but.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- This was your first movie.
- But this is the movie that
only means something to you.
- No, no, no.
It's just, I think of that coming of age,
like whenever I was a kid--
First of all, I watched
this movie with my kids.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- And I was like, holy (beep).
- You can't watch this with your kids.
I forgot how much cursing is in it.
I was like (laughs), and I was like--
But yeah, I was like (yells),
just trying to be louder
than what was happening.
But I didn't realize what I was watching
when I was a kid, but--
- I'm watching you right now
like you watch The Goonies.
You talking about The Goonies
is as entertaining for me
as you watching The Goonies.
- I'm telling you, I was
such a fan of the movie,
and it was one of those--
- So, who's your favorite character?
I'm sorry to interrupt, but
who's your favorite character?
- This is gonna get awkward,
- Not that you have to say.
- But we were gonna get
married, so that's why.
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd cheering)
No, no, no.
This is our picture, this is our picture.
(laughing)
(crowd cheering)